WAI CHEE DIMOCK: We're
starting today on Hemingway's
For Whom the Bell Tolls.
And as is frequently the case,
the title comes from a very
well known classic, in this case
John Donne's poem, which
is actually included
in the text of For
Whom the Bell Tolls.
So you guys can just go and
read it for on your own.
But I just thought that we'll
talk about it together, a very
famous phrase from a
very famous poem--
"No man is an island,
entire of itself.
Each is a piece of the
continent, a part of the main.
If a clod be washed away by the
sea, Europe is the less.
Each man's death diminishes
me, for I
am involved in mankind.
Therefore, send not for whom the
bell tolls, it tolls for
thee."
So a number of issues come
up in this poem--
justly famous poem--
that even though we
have separate
bodies, Donne's argument--
and in fact throughout his
entire poetic corpus--
is that our separate bodies
sometimes become optical
illusion and also experiential
illusion as well.
We feel that we're just one
unit, but we are actually tied
in so many different ways
to other people.
So the death of other people
would diminish me in the sense
that those ties will be cut
when those people die.
But also there's a more
disturbing sense that the
manner of death of other people
is in some sense also a
kind of a prelude, and an
analogy, and a suggestion of
the way that we would die.
So the bell is tolling for
someone else right now, but
sooner or later it's
going to toll for
myself, for you and me.
Death is central.
It's absolutely central to
For Whom the Bell Tolls.
It's not just a general argument
about the importance
of interconnections.
It's really about our
interconnections and death.
No other work by Hemingway is so
centrally meditating on the
phenomenon of dying and what
it is to die a good death.
So we'll come back to this.
But today that wouldn't
be the focus.
And instead today we'll be
talking mostly about the
Spanish Civil War, which is a
very important context for
this novel.
And it's very important
to get some historical
facts under our belt.
So basically, the two sides of
The Spanish Civil War are the
Republicans and the
Nationalists.
The Republicans are sometimes
referred to as the Loyalists.
And this phrase is sometimes
misleading, because it
suggests that maybe the
Loyalists are on the right.
But this is actually
not the case.
The Republicans are on the left,
but they're loyal to the
legitimately elected
government.
The Spanish Republic had
an elected government.
And so the Loyalists
were loyal to that.
They were protecting the
Spanish Republic.
And the reason we know that they
are on the left is that
they're backed by Mexico, which
is understandable given
the Spanish connection.
But they were also backed by the
Soviet Union So there are
lots of references to Russians
in this novel, from Russian
planes, to Russian cigarettes,
to Russians
at the Hotel Gaylord--
so lots and lots of Russians,
a Russian general in the
opening pages of the novel.
So the Soviet Union was a
central presence in his novel.
But more than that, the reason
that the Spanish Civil War has
gone down in history as such
an important war is that it
was supported by 30,000
international volunteers
making up the international
brigades, including people
from Poland, France, England,
and lots of volunteers from
the United States.
So the United States volunteers
were called the
Abraham Lincoln Brigade.
And then so all this is on the
Republican side, on the side
of the Spanish Republic.
And then opposing that, fighting
that, and eventually
triumphant in prevailing
over them would be the
Nationalists.
In this novel, Hemingway does
not refer to the Nationalists
as the Nationalists.
The word never comes up.
He refers to them as Fascists.
And the word has such a
pejorative ring now that it
seems as if he's condemning
them ahead of time.
But actually, in the
1930s fascist was
just a neutral word.
That was the party,
the Fascist Party.
So even though now historians
would refer to that side as
the Nationalist side, in my
lectures I'll be referring to
them as Fascists, just because
that's the word
that Hemingway uses.
And the Fascists were backed
by Germany and Italy.
So we see lots of German
planes as well,
Italian planes as well.
And the victory of the
Fascists led to the
dictatorship of General Franco,
who would go on to
rule Spain for many years.
So we know the outcome
of that war.
And it's a very tragic outcome
according to many people.
One of the great photographers
of the war was Robert Capa.
And fortunately, many of his
images are now available in
the public domain.
So this is Robert Capa
photographing the
Spanish Civil War.
And this is the most
iconic image.
It's 1936 the death of a
Loyalist Republican soldier.
And most of Capa's pictures tend
to be about the death of
just one person, a kind of a
visceral reaction to the death
that person.
And kind of blurry as well,
because that's probably how
death will feel when
it comes to us.
It's that we don't have a very
distinct sensation of that
condition when we're
going through it.
At least I think that's the
rationale behind it, other
than the fact that he was just
on site taking the picture
right there.
Here is another picture by
Robert Capa, again 1936, at
the very beginning of the war.
And these people were just
college students.
This was University
City in Madrid.
Most of the people who
fought in the Spanish
Civil War were civilians.
They were just students,
lots of women actually.
This was a war known for the
presence of women fighting.
So in many ways, because these
were just volunteers, it
wasn't a very high tech war.
And Robert Capa had a lot
of footage about this
very low tech war.
And basically this is the war
that we see in For Whom the
Bell Tolls.
Just one or two people walking
through the mountains just
trudging along talking to
small groups of people,
completely kind of local
initiative, and not just in
the cities but also in
the countryside.
And we should remember that in
For Whom the Bell Tolls it's
actually behind the lines.
They are behind the
enemy lines.
One possibility would be to go
back to the Spanish Republic,
to cross the enemy lines
and go back and join
with the main forces.
But the people that we see in
For Whom the Bell Tolls were
the guerrillas, who would be in
conditions such as these.
So this is the kind of the
iconic images of just
civilians fighting to defend
the Spanish Republic.
But the reason that it was such
a big global event was
that it was actually an
incredibly high-tech war.
So it was a very important link
between the First World
War and the Second World War.
And we know that the alliances
in the Spanish Civil War,
Germany and Italy, would go on
to become the Axis Powers in
the Second World War--
so a very, very important
link between those
two great world wars.
Itself the Spanish Civil War
was a world war of sorts,
given the number of
international participants.
So tanks are very important.
And the Republicans actually
used tractors, but the
Fascists had real tanks.
And we see them, the tanks,
in full force.
And this is the final image of
the triumph of the tanks.
The fascists entering
Madrid March, 1939.
And the next month the
republic, the Spanish
Republic, surrendered
to the Fascists.
So we know the outcome
very well.
It was basically a
very short war.
But because they were
defending an elected
government, the international
sentiment was on the side of
the Spanish Republic.
And this is a very famous
painting by the Spanish
painter Joan Miro.
But you'll notice that the
language is actually not
Spanish, "Aidez Espagne." That's
French, because he
couldn't stay in Spain anymore
after the outbreak of the war.
So he had to flee to France,
and this was actually in
exhibition in Paris.
So that's why the language
was in French.
And French will actually come
up a little bit in For Whom
the Bell Tolls as well
-- or as France.
So it's kind of an interesting
side reference that we'll be
talking about next time.
But lots and lots of images
of international aid--
once again, mostly very
nonmilitary looking people
were giving aid to do the
Spanish Republic.
So these were artists
in London just
giving medical supplies.
But the Americans were there in
full force, and this is the
Abraham Lincoln Brigade.
They're actually the best
equipped volunteers.
There were pictures of
volunteers from Poland.
And they actually looked kind
of sad, to begin with, even
without the fighting.
But the Americans were very well
equipped, and they looked
very healthy and
ready to fight.
And they were also
very, very young.
So it was a very glamorous war,
in one sense, because of
all young people who
were fighting.
And women there, as we can see,
and in the beginning of
the war there was lots of
musical entertainment.
And it seemed like
fun, initially.
It quickly stopping being fun,
as we can tell from the novel.
So Hemingway was there.
He was a war correspondent.
He was covering the war with the
Republicans here and this
rare image of him actually
holding a gun.
He wasn't supposed
to fight them.
I don't think he actually
fought, but just in case he
needed to do something.
So it oddly suggests that one
way to think about the novel
would be to think about a kind
of divide in the novel --
a kind of structural
principle --
in terms of voluntary
association versus involuntary
association.
Voluntary association, obviously
the International
Brigades, all these people did
not have to fight in the war.
They all voluntarily put
themselves in danger for
political reasons, so very much
voluntary association.
And there's lots of glory, and
honor, and pleasure from that,
pride from that.
And then on the opposite side
would be involuntary
association.
Now we get labeled
as foreigners.
The Americans get labeled
Robert Jordan gets labeled
as a foreigner.
He's not even given the dignity
of being an American.
He's referred to as the Ingles,
the English, so they
even get his national
identity wrong.
But it doesn't really matter.
He's just one of those
foreigners.
So foreigner is a kind of
involuntary association, a
generic type.
And then the ultimate
involuntary association would
be the company of the dead.
It's a very large company, and
very few of us are ready to
join them, right now, but we
are put in that company.
So going back to Donne,
obviously --
but also going back to pretty
much all the text that we've
been talking about
all semester.
So we've been talking about this
phenomenon of involuntary
association, in terms of
individual and type.
So I just want to go back, very
quickly, to refresh your
memory about all this text.
In To Have and Have Not,
Harry's involuntary
association would be with all
the other "have nots." And
there were plenty of them during
the Great Depression.
That would be an involuntary
association for him.
But luckily for him, he actually
can qualify that
involuntary association when
he's mediated by the presence
of Marie, when he becomes this
very wonderful and long
lasting, not perishing,
figure in her mind.
And when he's mediated in
contrast to Richard Gordon.
In the Fitzgerald stories "Rich
Boy" and "Bernice Bobs
Her Hair," we have the
involuntary association
through type.
So rich boy Anson Hunter,
he has as an involuntary
association with the title of
the story "Rich Boy." But he
deviates so much.
I mean, he's such an extreme
example that
he's almost a deviation.
And Bernice reverts to
a much more ancient
type, the Native American.
So they all have a kind of
qualified involuntary
association to the immediate
surroundings.
And As I Lay Dying, which we
just finished discussing, is
Faulkner's version of To
Have and Have Not.
And actually there it seems that
the concept of "have not"
is most tenacious and in many
ways victorious at the end,
triumphant at the end.
In the sense that Darl really
is involuntarily confined to
Jackson, he has an involuntary
sojurn in a mental
institution.
So that is--
in many ways Faulkner is the
most pessimistic of those
three writers.
Today we'll look at the
complicated sevenfold
permutations in For Whom
the Bell Tolls.
And we won't be talking about
all of them today.
So this pretty much is the
pattern or the structure for
the next four lectures.
But I just want to give you a
sense of what we're talking
about, individuals versus type
obviously, voluntary versus
involuntary, and given the
fact that the setting is
Spain, foreign versus
not foreign.
And the question of language
brings up the question of
literacy and illiteracy.
And the relation between the
distant home and the on-site
environment is going to be very
important, because the
United States actually has quite
an important presence in
this novel.
So that's the relation between
the United States and Spain.
And something that we've been
talking about all the way
through, comic versus tragic,
and finally, to
have and have not.
So all of this we'll
be talking about in
the next two weeks.
But today we'll concentrate on
the concept of involuntary
foreigners.
And it turns out that there are
actually two classes of
involuntary foreigners, one
completely counterintuitive.
We would think that the
involuntary foreigners would
just be Americans.
They are the obvious
foreigners.
And Hemingway gives us multiple
instances of when one
could be an involuntary
foreigner.
But I think that he is an astute
enough reader of the
future and of the global
dimension of the Spanish Civil
War to know that the Spanish
could also be involuntary
foreigners in their
own country.
This is happening all
the time now.
Lots and lots of people are
involuntary foreigners in
their country.
It is one of the most common
phenomena of the
twenty-first century.
And Hemingway is portraying some
of that already during
the Spanish Civil War, because
of the phenomena of print
illiteracy and because of
technological illiteracy that,
again, is a very, very common.
So let's just start on
the American side.
We know that Hemingway is
actually very, very good in
being considerate of those of
us who don't know Spanish or
who just know a few
words in Spanish.
When he uses a Spanish word
phrase, he would give us the
translation almost right away.
So we have no trouble
understanding the
Spanish in the novel.
But he does have this
interesting stylistic
innovation of inflecting the
English language in the
direction of Spanish.
So the classic example is the
unidiomatic expression, "How
are you called?" It is
what's your name.
We don't go around asking
people, how are you called,
because Spanish is not really
the reference point for most
of us at any rate, in this
country, not yet.
But in Spain that's the form
English would take, even in
your own head.
What you would ask people all
the time is, "Como se llama
Usted?" "How are you
called," literally
translated from that.
And it's a more formal
expression.
"Tu" is not to someone
that you know well.
It's a more formal expression,
addressing someone that maybe
you're meeting for the first
time, someone who's older,
showing more respect
for the person or
distance from the person.
What is the effect of this
kind of English, not
translated into Spanish
words but translated
into Spanish syntax?
It is not the actual translation
into Spanish words
but translation using
the syntactical
structure of Spanish.
I think that there are many
effects, depending on your
degree of knowledge of
Spanish, really.
It could be irritating--
I imagine actually-- for
a Spanish speaker.
But I think that for people
who actually have a very
slight acquaintance with Spanish
the effect is the kind
of a double alienation.
We should take note of
the fact that this
is unidiomatic English.
And we're struggling to think of
the Spanish equivalent for
that that would be the origin
for the English phrase.
In any case, it makes us aware
of how English actually is not
translatable word for word
into the Spanish.
What's your name cannot
be translated word
for word into Spanish.
So it highlights the
non-translatability of English.
And the fact that there really
are very important
cross-cultural barriers, not
least of all in language as a
the cross-cultural barrier.
Certain things cannot
get across easily.
They cannot get across
without modification.
So Hemingway gives us no
illusion that you can fit
easily into a different
environment.
He gives us no illusion that
there could be this immediate
communion between people from
different cultural and
linguistic backgrounds.
I think that the effect of this
double alienation is also
to make us aware of sometimes
how strange the English
language would be.
So every time you know more
than one language, you're
aware of how each of those
languages is actually quite
strange in peculiar instances.
So it makes everyone a sort
of involuntary foreigner.
Even though you're still
at home, really.
You're still a native speaker
of one language.
The fact that you're aware of
other languages into which
your own native language
cannot be automatically
translated makes you almost a
foreigner, a slight foreigner
in your own native language.
But this is a very mild and
really not painful form, I
think, of being a foreigner.
Things start getting more
painful, very fast actually,
in For Whom the Bell Tolls.
But people still
joke about it.
So here is Robert Jordan
talking to the Russian
general, Golz.
I don't actually know it's
pronounced in Russian.
But they were talking
about the bridge.
And we know that Robert
is supposed
to blow-up the bridge.
So they were actually
talking business.
And Robert Jordan is assuring
the Russian general that he
knows exactly what to do, that
he's a very good engineer.
He is very good with
explosives.
And this is what Golz says,
"'I believe you do.'"--
do know how to blow-up
the bridge--
"'I will not make you
any little speech.
Let us have a drink.
So much talking makes
me very thirsty.
Commrade Hordan.
You have a funny name in Spanish
Comrade Hordown.
How do you say Golz in Spanish,
Comrade General?'
'Holze,' said Golz, grinning,
making the sound deep in his
throat as though hawking
with a bad cold.
'Hotze,' he croaked.
'Comrade Heneral Khorze.
If I had known how they
pronounce Golz in Spanish I
would pick me out a better
name before I come to war
here.'"
So the Spanish "G" and "J"
sounds are pronounced as "H."
So that's why it's especially
disconcerting when you have
the combination of those, as
in Comrade General Golz.
I can't even say it now.
I'm so confused.
It is really totally
alienating.
Your own name becomes
unrecognizable
in a foreign language.
Most of the time it
doesn't happen.
But it just so happens that in
this one instance, there
really is kind of a double
alienation going on for Golz.
So what does it mean when your
own name is not pronounceable?
There's just no equivalent
sound in Spanish.
It could be a really innocent
and completely innocuous or
trivial occurrence.
But for something like that,
one is almost involuntarily
tempted to read more
meaning into that.
There's just no Spanish
equivalent for my own identity.
In that language there's
no room.
There's no place.
There's just no slot that
is waiting for me
that I can fit in.
There's just no sound that will
reproduce a necessary
sound in English.
So it really raises the question
of what kind of a
place Robert Jordan could have
in the Spanish community.
If there's no linguistic, if
there's no phonetic slot for
him in the Spanish language,
would there be a social slot
for him in that Spanish
community?
Would there be a
functional slot
for him in that community?
He has a very, very well-defined
function.
He's there to blow
up the bridge.
And as long as he sticks to that
very limited function.
He's probably OK.
There's room for someone who
will blow up bridges and
leave.
But the thing is people can't
actually just confine
themselves to that very,
very narrow definition.
It would be unbearable,
actually, to be no more than
just someone who's there to
blow up the bridge and do
nothing else.
You can't just have that very,
very narrow existence.
So Robert Jordan has
got to have some
relations to the people.
And once he wanders away from
that very straight, very
narrow definition things
will get problematic.
And that's why there's
so much tension
between him and the Spanish.
So one other instance of
involuntary association and
being an involuntary
foreigner--
and the word foreigner is
actually used by the Spanish a
lot, probably to
insult Robert.
So Pablo is actually the one
who's especially aggressive
when it comes to that.
"'There was a foreigner with us
who made the explosions. '
Pablo said.
'Do you know him?' 'What was he
called?' 'I do not remember.
It was a very rare name.' "What
did he look like?' 'He
was fair, as you are, but not as
tall with large hands and a
broken nose.' 'Kashkin,"
Robert Jordan said.
"That would be Kashkin."
'Yes,' said Pablo.
'It was a very rare name.
Something like that.' 'What
became of him?' 'He is dead
since April.'"
A number of things--
we actually don't know if
Pablo remembers the name
Kashkin or not.
For all we know, he might
actually be able to remember
name very well.
They don't have foreigners
every day among them and
Kashkin is not such a hard
name to remember.
He probably knows the name.
He's emphatic about not knowing
the name, not being
able to recall the name.
Even when offered the name, he
refuses to repeat the name--
"Something like that"--
just a generic foreigner.
So nothing can be more
aggressive indirectly, by way
of talking dismissively
about Kashkin as
a forgettable foreigner.
Because he's just a generic
type, he's just there to make
the explosions.
So in all these ways, he's
making this forgettable,
unimportant, probably not
liked foreigner the
predecessor for Robert Jordan.
And there's a kind of an
unforeseen consequence of
making Kashkin the predecessor
for Robert.
And Pablo probably doesn't
know that, but Kashkin
actually had died.
And we know later on that he
had died he had died by
killing himself.
His job is to blow up bridges
or blow up trains.
But he's just terrified of doing
it, and so he killed
himself, which Robert
only knows.
So a combination of deliberate
aggression from Pablo, in
turning the foreigner into a
generic type into which both
Kashkin and Robert would
be inserted.
That deliberate aggression from
Pablo combined with a
circumstance that he probably
wouldn't have known--
that Kashkin is dead
at this point--
all of this made the dead
foreigner, not just a
foreigner but a dead foreigner,
the sort of
scripted future for
Robert Jordan.
It's not just that
foreigners cannot
assimilate into the community.
But they also have a tendency
to die very soon.
That seems to be the forecast
for Robert Jordan.
And so we don't know if
this forecast will
actually become reality.
It's just a possibility
at this point.
But it's a very, very emphatic
possibility that is
underscored numerous times
actually by other people,
every time Kashkin comes up, how
he died and the fact that
he's like Robert
in many ways --
fair haired foreigner --
all those things come up.
So it's the kind
of a signature.
It's kind of a structural
signature, narrative signature
in terms of the punctuation that
Hemingway puts into his
novel, all those places when
we stop and wonder is a
similar fate awaiting Robert
Jordan, similar to Kashkin.
So the company of the dead--
I think it's fair to say--
is never very far.
It's always on the horizon.
In fact, it's not even
on the horizon.
It's a looming presence
in that community.
And it's a looming presence,
especially for foreigners in
that community.
So that's pretty bad
for Americans.
We don't actually see
a lot of Americans.
We just see one,
Robert Jordan.
So it's pretty bad.
The signs and omens
are not good.
But it seems that the signs and
omens are also not great
for the Spanish, as well.
And we can look at the ways in
which they are involuntary
foreigners in their
own countries.
And actually Robert Jordan is
also quite aggressive in
making sure that the Spanish can
sometimes feel like they
don't quite own their
own country.
They don't know how things are
done in their own country.
Robert has a piece of paper to
prove his credentials, which
is necessary given the fact
that no one knows
anything about him.
So how would people know
he's on their side?
So he has pieces of documents to
prove that he is, in fact,
well credentialed.
"He handed it to the man who
opened it, looked at it
doubtfully, and turned
it in his hands.
So he cannot read, Robert
Jordan noted.
'Look at the seal,' he said.
The old man pointed to the seal,
and the man with the
carbine studied it, turning
it in his fingers.
'What seal is that?' 'Have you
never seen it?' 'No' 'There
are two,' said Robert Jordan.
'One is the SIM, the Service of
the Military Intelligence.
The other is the General Staff.'
'Yes, I've seen that
seal before, but here no one
commands but me,' the man said
solemnly."
So there obviously is a struggle
for authority here.
It is a shock to us
that Pablo --
and in fact all the people that
we see in this novel --
all the Spanish they
are all illiterate.
And usually we don't even have
to specify it's print
illiteracy.
But here it seems especially
important to point it out,
because they're very literate
in other senses.
We know that Anselmo actually
speaks a classical Spanish, or
Castilian Spanish, which is very
pure in this language of
literature, of Quevedo.
So they are actually very
literate in the sense of
having a very, very
distinguished literary
tradition behind them,
but oral tradition.
So they can't read writing.
But obviously in the twentieth
century, early in the
twentieth century, not to be
able to read and write is a
tremendous liability.
So right, there's one strike
against all of these Spanish
who cannot read their own
language in writing.
It is Robert, the foreigner, who
can actually read Spanish
writing, Spanish script.
But there's another level
of print illiteracy.
And it goes even beyond
language, in the fact that
there are two seals
on that document.
Pablo recognizes only
one of the seals.
He doesn't recognize
the other one.
He doesn't recognize the other
one because he's not high
enough on the military hierarchy
to have come across
the other seal before.
So in many ways, it is Robert's
way of putting him
down, showing that he actually
has more knowledge of the
military infrastructure
than Pablo does.
So that's why Pablo's very
sullen, angry response--
and completely understandable
response-- is no one commands
here but me.
Pablo's hope--
and actually this is a very
interesting hope--
that will be tested, and I think
to some degree supported
in the novel, is that it doesn't
really matter how high
up you are on the general
military infrastructure.
That in many ways, people who
actually know a community well
would be able to have command
of that community.
I'm just saying this now
as a possibility.
But certainly the contest of
authority between Pablo and
Robert will be played out
throughout the entire novel.
It's one of the most important
structural
features of this novel.
But print illiteracy is both
very nameable and it basically
defines who you are.
But it's kind of a general
condition.
But there are more specific
instances of illiteracy that I
would call technological
illiteracy.
And it has to do with the
high-tech warfare that we've
seen is also a central feature
of the Spanish Civil War.
He is talking about--
And I found myself actually
looking for images for lots of
military websites to find the
images for these weapons.
"'Hell, it's a Lewis gun,
Robert Jordan thought.
'Do you know anything about
a machine gun?' he
asked the old man.
'Nada,' said Anselmo.
'Nothing.'" Here is an
instance of Hemingway doing
instantaneous translation.
"'Nada,' said Anselmo
'Nothing.' 'And
thou?' to the gypsy.
'That they fire with such
rapidity and become so hot the
barracks burn the hand
that touches it.'
the gypsy said proudly.
'Unless they jam, run out of
ammunition, or get so hot the
melt,' Robert Jordan
said in English.
'What did you say?'
Anselmo asked him.
'Nothing,' Robert Jordan said.
'I was only looking into the
future in English.'"
This is a very aggressive moment
on the side of Robert.
Every time someone switches into
a language they know the
other person doesn't understand
it signals
intentionality.
It signals aggression.
But we'll stay away from that
for a moment and just look at
the Lewis gun.
This was a major innovation,
actually during World War I.
It started in World War I. And
it's a very complicated piece
of machinery.
So nobody would have
a kind of intuitive
command of this weapon.
And so here is just
one instance of
the Lewis gun drill.
You have to learn
to use the gun.
And we can see it's a
very, very big gun.
It's very unwieldy.
It's heavy.
And also, you just can't
hold it in your hand.
You have to put it on your
shoulder and carry it around.
It really is a major hindrance
to any kind of movement.
And here is an image of how
inconvenient actually, what a
pain it is actually
to use that gun.
It is a weapon that actually
creates, brings, produces that
facial expression on a person
who is trying to use that gun.
So it is understandable that
even Robert Jordan himself
would take note when he notices
that is a Lewis gun.
That is not just any
ordinary weaponry.
It's a special kind
of equipment.
And it signals a certain level
of fighting, a certain scale
of warfare, when the Lewis
gun is involved.
And it's because it signals a
certain scale of fighting,
that it's no longer a strictly
local affair, no longer
strictly based on local
knowledge and intuitive use of
small weapons.
I think that it's because of
all these reasons that he
would suddenly switch to
English, as if just giving
himself the license to think
out loud to himself in a
different language
at that point.
He doesn't think very highly of
the Lewis gun, even though
it's such an impressive looking,
cumbersome weapon.
It actually can jam or run
out of ammunition and
get so hot they melt.
So it's not a great weapon
to use, all around.
That's part of the reason he's
saying this in English, so
that the Spanish wouldn't know
all these drawbacks of these
high-tech weapons.
But also that people who use
the Lewis gun really have a
different relation to the future
than people who don't.
It's similar in the civilian
setting in the
twenty-first century.
People who don't have a computer
at this point, people
who've never used a computer,
have very different relation
to the future and to the present
than people who do.
It really is a sharp
dividing line.
So in the context of the Spanish
Civil War, people who
have never seen the Lewis gun,
have never handled one, have a
different relation
to the future.
So the gun itself is a
kind of a doorkeeper.
Various people are admitted in
having a viable relation to
the future and various people
are banned from having a
viable relation to the future.
Or they have a very diminished
and marginal
relation to the future.
So the gun is the doorkeeper.
And the English language, as far
as Robert understands it,
is lined up with the
gun in that way.
The gun is what is
on the ground.
And there's another weapon that
has wings that is also
very important to the
Spanish Civil War.
And we see the next installment
of this
technological illiteracy on
the side of the Spanish in
this exchange.
"--high in the evening sky,
three monoplanes in V
formation, showing minute and
silvery at that height where
there still was sun, passing
unbelievably quickly across
the sky, their motors now
throbbing steadily.
'Ours?' 'The seem so,' Robert
Jordan said but knew that at
that height you never
could be sure.
'They are Moscows,'
Anselmo said.
Robert Jordan could have put the
glasses on and been sure
instantly, but he preferred
not to.
It made no difference to him who
they were tonight and if
it pleased the old man to have
them be ours he did not want
to take them away.
Now as they moved out of sight
towards Segovia did not look
to be the green and red wing
tip low wing Russian
conversion of the Boeing
P32 that the
Spaniards called Moscows.
You could not see the colors
but the cut was wrong.
No.
It was a Fascist Patrol
coming home."
So knowledge of airplanes,
knowledge that actually I
think most of us in this room
probably don't have, but
anyway, this is the Moscow.
It's a Boeing P32.
And I don't know what else to
say about it, except that it
looks kind of primitive.
Actually, I did read somewhere
that this is the last of that.
There were various previous
incarnations, the Boeing P29
or something.
This is the last, and
then Boeing just
stopped developing this.
This is the last of the line.
If we look at actually the
German planes, the Heinkels,
were very, very effective
bombers.
They actually look much more
impressive than the Moscows.
You can see that this is a plane
that anyone can see can
do serious damage.
And here is the Italian Fiat and
Anselmo is to be forgiven
for mistaking the Italian Fiat
for the Boeing P32, because
actually they are short,
and they are
kind of clumsy looking.
And we can see right away that,
even though this is the
Spanish Civil War, the Nazi
insignia is there.
So this really is the Second
World War intruding into the
Spanish Civil War.
No question that Hemingway is
using the word Fascist in a
very deliberate way.
And this is a much more
effective version of the
Spanish bombers.
We'll be talking about all
of this and the actual
destruction of some of the
people in this novel, what the
bombers, what the Italian
bombers can do to a local
population.
But I just want to go back to
that phrase about looking into
the future in English.
We've talked a lot about
tomorrows and the future,
beginning with The Sound
and the Fury.
And the way in which the
tomorrow of Benjy, and the
tomorrow of Jason, and the
tomorrow of Quentin are in
many ways very pale versions
of the present.
That it's not a future
that one can inhabit.
And here it raises the question
of whether the future
can be inhabited by Spanish
speakers who don't know
English at all.
In this context there's just
no way that the Spanish
could-- note that this local
community, they can't really
read Spanish in writing--
there's almost no way they can
read the future in English.
But it also doesn't feel like
this is a future that, even if
you were able to read, that
you would want to live in,
even if you have the ability to
read that future, even if
that future is writ-large
by the Lewis
gun and by the planes.
That is a very legible future,
written on the
sky and on the ground.
Even though that's such a
legible future and you can
read it, it might still not be
a future that you would want
to move into, not a
future that you
would want to inhabit.
So this is a way in which
there's also a kind of a
double alienation going on.
The Spanish are banned from
that future, because they
simply cannot read it.
It is illegible to them.
Robert Jordan, who can read
just fine, is also in many
ways, an outsider to that
future because it's not
anything that he would
like to live in.
It's not a world that he
would like to live in.
And I just want to give you
two final images of what
happens to the Spanish
historically because of the
use of bombers in the
Spanish Civil War.
This is the most famous town.
It was completely destroyed by
Italian bombers, Guernica.
And this is the famous Picasso
painting, and we can see this
is really the response of
a low-tech population to
high-tech warfare.
You've just never seen anything
like that before.
So it is nightmarish.
It is surreal in the sense that
the world has turned into
a different kind of reality.
It just has no relation to
reality as you know it.
And that's why it is surreal.
And that's why Cubism is, in
many ways, a response to the
surreal scenarios conjured up
by the high-tech weaponry
of world wars.
So we'll come back to this and
talk more about, basically,
the phenomenon of dying both in
isolation but also of dying
as a result of something
that is large and that
is coming at you.